find the perimeter of a rectangle with
the length and width given below express
your answer as a simplified rational
expression and state
the domain
all right so they give us the length the
length is this rational expression the
width is that right there and if we just
draw ourselves a rectangle let's draw
ourselves a rectangle up here so we
don't
use valuable real estate if that's the
width and that is the length the
perimeter of this rectangle is going to
be the width plus the length times two
because you have two widths right here
if two lengths so you could view that as
w plus w plus l plus l which is the same
thing as
two w plus two l which is the same thing
as two times the width plus the length
so we have to find out what two times
two times the width plus the length is
as a rational expression so let's write
that down so the perimeter the perimeter
is going to be equal to
two times 2 times
2 times the width plus the length or we
can say the length plus the width either
way so the width is x
minus 3y
over x plus 4. and then the length is so
plus 2x
plus 5y
over x plus 4
and let's add these two rational
expressions we have the same denominator
so we can just add the numerators so
this is going to be equal to 2 times the
denominator is going to be x plus 4. we
have the same denominator
so this problem wasn't too hairy we
didn't have to come up with a common
denominator and we're going to have x
minus 3y plus 2x plus 5y in the
numerator so let's just simplify we have
our x terms you have an x
plus a 2x so that's going to give us a
3x in the numerator and then you have a
negative 3x and a 5y in the numerator so
that'll negative 3 plus 5 is plus
2 y in the numerator
and then we can multiply out this 2 we
can distribute this 2 and then we end up
with
we have 2 times 3x is 6x 2 times 2i is
4y plus 4y
all of that over
x
all of that over x plus 4. and there's
really no way to simplify this anymore
and you know in this example out here we
actually had the two factored out and 3x
plus 2y no common factors it's not going
to cancel with x plus 4. and when they
say state the domain
state the domain we just have to think
about the x values that will that aren't
part of the domain that would make this
that would make either of these
expressions or this final expression
undefined or actually all they care
about is the final expression and the
thing that would make the final
expression undefined is if this
denominator is equal to zero and the
denominator is going to be equal to zero
when x is equal to negative 4.
so we can just constrain the domain and
say x cannot be equal to negative 4 that
we are not defining that this is
undefined at x equals negative 4. so the
simplified rational expression for the
perimeter 6 plus four y over x plus four
x cannot be negative four